hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm back with you yamimash hello
everyone i'm yeah i'm at that was so
much more calm than when i was leading
you into it's been a while you can't be
a little more peppy wow we just have to
do our intro we're taking all these uses
madam trade secrets we didn't screw up
at all everything goes right the first
you screw don't know we there's no we in
then what we're a team we have to do
you're going ready I'm Freddie we have
to be a team like gone go to Freddie on
the leader that's a cool one leader I'm
the leader
ready bull demises the dynamic duo is
back exactly and I'm golden
of course okay yeah whatever fake gold
okay so we're playing there's bills
what's this map called Ian escape your
dream escape your dreams alright would
you like to do the honors of pushing
button didn't do anything
alright probably hello I'll press it
again you first
I'll be fine because I'll be predicted
by the couch boo oh no we died off the
bat we're totally fine okay crouch jump
you're inside me there we go oh I fell
down apparently there we go
hey Wow listen this creep is the world
just slightly tilted do you know maybe
you're a chilling yo camera or something
my head is just a little bit counter
Wumpus of what oh no I turned my head
and I'm good now let's go in the ceiling
might have screwed up your neck of it
you do that how's it going well wood is
this map is spooky scary you back clean
that back up you demon ghost yeah
exactly
put that back where it came from puzzles
on this map apparently there are and
we're not allowed to use a fist gun to
put it away wait for time I bring out
the camera my head goes tilted tilted
huh it's my head tilted 1/2 the camera
okay bring out the fist gun I'll solve
the problem no it makes us cinematic 2 3
5 feel artistic when I'm counter to the
machi mash mu Z coming to theaters video
don't encourage people if the market
match movie actually existed it wouldn't
be duper a crowd with all the fun girls
okay looks like there's a pickaxe here
you know I grabbed all three of the
wrenches or whatever they're called
oh it's crowbar we're yeah Oh
closing the door behind us Mac cuz it
came from that way sure she's not
wearing pants are you not wearing any
shirt either I don't know what I should
be more concerned about sir if you
forget they bet my meat on his body
I think he's got plenty of meat on his
buddy that's not his problem I'm pretty
sure the problem is that he's dead he
doesn't have a face I'm naked well that
sounded fun let's go through here now
what's the noise these tunnels don't
look right there's something definitely
wrong with this this is something
definitely wrong with your head clipping
to the top
whoa whoa I was turned around looking at
you when that happened come back this
way my dummy broke open oh whoa hey whoa
all right yeah man yes spit all over me
yeah I know I anyone I play games with I
get my spit on them through the internet
to straight through my microphone to be
a lot of sense
oh you sassy sue these guys bow ready
for me okay maturity time remember we're
mature adults yes we are mature adults
we've been playing well hey hello shadow
people how are you doing are you sure
you want to walk up to them yeah Morgan
I'm doing right now
boy batter right now go move aside mark
okay cool all right yeah this is one
direction right
uh yeah what's a One Direction song
you're beautiful guys everybody wants to
steal my girl everybody wanna take her
heart away anytime you wanna join in the
song that would be really cool and be
okay
you didn't taking patrons damn thing
there I'll go in for you to join in
there Larry you know the lyrics to one
direction will make you beautiful lights
up the world's like no one else yeah no
no no Normans from Einsteins right no no
no no you probably shouldn't have even
tried what are you walking away for
become bad I'm just it was so good I
couldn't head back ass
oh look the secret under the boxes oh
wow dead human body parts with some
finally that's my secret
that's just hunky that's a burn dead guy
well we're bad right there
oh there wow you brought him up he's
gone why I cook 10 hours fun do I need
this for any reason because this
important this seems like it's
definitely nine point you worry about it
very weird
are you talking to me about fancy words
Oh knocking on this door okay I don't
think I'm gonna take my piece of wool oh
the doors open now oh hey Tony rituals
the anime girl what happened Freddie
what did you do anything she was like
this when I got here
you're you so huh anyway I'm actually a
police man you're arrested for the child
abuse for what she's an adult
whoa okay whoa
something just I picked up the piece of
wood and everything just pushed okay so
I got this piece of wood you get that
piece of wood oh I need to beat the wood
okay yeah apparently they're gonna be
used for something I don't know what
what's up yo Hey
Oh No I will follow you a big bad hairy
ass thank you it's not hairy
I get Brazilian wax every day you're not
doing a good job with I myself not know
an attractive sound Sam hey okay how did
you go can you stop staring in the
mirror you need to meet this what I have
to put up and every time I talk you out
of it I looked over and like the way my
flashlight made your face hey Friday
dance at you dead
dad you look so good I hope I don't grow
up to be like you son no dad no yet
again not your whip I'll hide in Winnie
bathroom stalls go to your room you
grounded me and cheek are gonna have
some words about wage my room has to be
a bathroom stall dad I just want to make
you proud years cuz all you are is a
piece of [ __ ] gonna be so rude
come on oh wait yeah I love you dad
[Music]
it's my crying I'm crying dad okay okay
what was this Freddy's laugh sound like
if that's his crying same thing oh oh
[Music]
okay open the door
all right fine whatever
Jesus yeah oh why did you put the wood
by the way who's yeah it was somewhere
out there oh you left outside the door
somewhere out there it's right there
down the ladder over there okay we got
build it I know there's like another two
or three of them in that bunk okay
well that's - oh look is another one of
those fancy things
why not fancy things it's a cart is it
so free
oh there's babies in it oh oh why didn't
you tell me
oh there's beautiful bouncing babies
you're officially a father is that tasty
mom I'm not eating the baby woman okay
all right there is something definitely
wrong with you ADA's are missing it's
missing limbs
miss miss Oh on top of this shelf
there's a another wooden piece all right
you grab that one I'm just gonna stand
one stop of this ritual that's gonna
kill ya if you come back here there's
actually some markings on the I need to
record for posterity get my camera I
need to make sure I get this recorded
nothing here what does tunnel then that
sounds safe
all right you just done that literally
nothing here way that she nothing
there's actually nothing here
well that's why I'm not standing on
because there's doors in the way Hanlon
move this smooth the dough use your
physics going on something
[Music]
there's literally nothing there Wow all
right then oh she was dead whoa
[Music]
no no wait a minute
I have an idea
one Harwich oh no you don't hear a good
joke thank you laughs why did you go
away when I go over here okay how are
you having so much fun with this
I don't know you're not seeing the fun
that I'm havin so so why did chica cross
the road
why did she to get to the pieces Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was huh hey I thought a door about it
no you need something to put out the
fire oh do you have a fire in your loins
where you needed you need something
putting out fire in my heart for you
mark
oh that's so romantic oh oh woah-oh
there's another piece of wood I got
banished back to the beginning why why
am I here okay I fell in a hole if I
died you have to rely on me now I'm the
boss of this relationship be nice to me
or I'm just gonna leave you behind
alright fine mr. golden Freddy sir
golden Freddy I have you know mr. sir
golden Freddy sir and am I made of real
gold no no not the answer Mac yes it's
real gold it's real like two karat gold
and who's hotter me it's stupid alright
I got it I got a quench this fire hey
wait
if we get things hot and heavy things
will get moist enough in here that it
will put out the fire so come myself
close the door
alright come on all right here we go
golden Freddy there you
[Laughter]
oh I'm actually okay I'm okay all right
I completed the ladder by the way while
you was messing about have they ever
been respectful of me thank you guy he's
back the store closed whoa that door
closed
oh whoa there's someone at the end of
the hallway I can see why but not wanted
hello girls what is funny I'm not
entirely sure but the doors are open now
hmm I see it seems like a trap okay I
got a fire extinguisher now should I
jump down with you uh maybe try it once
I just seem to be stuck okay whoa the
fire extinguisher what the hell are we
we're back where we were okay still put
out that red-hot fire
see I told you
hello hello did you see me Friday oh it
worked good jump Friday hey we can over
the lock door that's got a scar I'm
going I'm going as fast as I can
I had this presents inside there's
presents from see you see this present
and they're all for you Freddie oh boy
quick run I don't know [ __ ] all right
I'm runnin I'm runnin okay okay whoa a
new computer oh you need to find three
books to open this door that's from a
movie I watched oh I found the fund or
fund or the funder or oh okay
the music is crescendoing yes that makes
building up towards us these doors are
locked
we have a time ahead we might just be we
can figure it our smart we're smart
where's Martin we're smart we're super
smart you're trying to press the buttons
on this thing but it's not doing
anything
wait this this this shelf is lookie-loo
looky-loo good job mom
we did it you did it okay okay give me
damn food
give me damn food oh I'll give you some
for Freddy I I don't want you to be
ready for Freddy hello hey you it's a
slap you are you going to slap me huh
these are dancing for real
oh you want to go you want to go brah
ray got nothing afraid of you huh
okay Jesus don't you hit a woman Friday
I wasn't hitting a woman she was hitting
me I told you you was too big okay
wait this seems bad how do we need some
type of material to walk on oh oh how
about the rope on the wall just jump up
on it and climb over it's like a ladder
try press e on it or something
hey golden freddy sir who has the power
now who is a dumb dumb and who literally
just jumped towards it and jump up keep
moving forward when you jump up on it
come on don't go down too far don't go
down okay there you are you do not wait
a minute wait a minute mature gentlemen
let us do not be needing these words
exactly yes this is immaturity - Maximus
inappropriate I believe the rudeness of
those words that I saw oh hey animes on
let's go watch I'm oh I don't really but
anime is something okay cool
I like this metal alkyl is I like death
no cuz I'm kind of emo
hello hello I don't know what this is
from doesn't sound too good what is
going on - I'm subtle flapping going on
she seems to be you know kind of enjoy
I don't know every time I pick it up by
is impressive Oh Oh something smashing
my boom box watermelon do you like it
amazing buddy what are you going dragons
ender
okay I'm gonna play stairway to heaven
[Music]
like that okay I feed the hungry person
with it oh I'm okay I think I'm gonna
[Music]
come having belly noises just feel yes
this is rock music from the one are you
gonna be okay I'll just I'll play the
dramatic music of you trying to get up
on time jump higher I'm trying this is
hot Oh put more music in behind this
this is not this is not bad you dated
this pine you know what the woman she
exploded she exploded
I just thought she ran away with it no
obviously it was a watermelon bomb and
wouldn't have given it to her
yes filled of cone blah that's not
trying to go about but I'll trying to
give you those pills earlier but : blue
well first I need to get some eyes in my
head but then yeah yeah you couldn't see
it yeah I enjoyed it not bad at all
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out yami masters channel for
another video that we just did with
another scary map and also check out all
the cool videos that I've done with
yamimash in the past we've been playing
for about three years now so on and off
like recently we haven't played as much
but we're gonna play a lot more in the
future so check them out it's a great
history of my channel and his channel so
thanks again everybody and as always oh
well say any parting words
it was great playing come over and check
out my one all right thanks buddy
and as always we will see you in the
nation
[Music]